[Music]
next speaker is adil salims presenting a
talk on sampling as optimization
hi
can you see my slides
okay no
[Music]
okay once again
can you hear me
we can see your swipes on zoom uh are
the slides also visible in the
auditorium
you can start your video okay yes your
host
okay so the the title has changed a bit
but uh it's still about something
so i'm going to talk about
um which is a famous sampling algorithm
used in several contexts in machine
learning
and specifically about its complexity
analysis
okay start my video perfect thanks
uh
okay let's start
so what do we want to do uh what we want
to do is to sample from some target
distribution u star
whose density is proportional to
exponential minus f so this is a
standard task in many uh many machine
learning applications
and uh here our assumptions are that the
function f here is a is smooth
and
and uh and we do not assume that the
function is convex
so we work with rg so our goal is to
sample over rz but let me illustrate
what we want to do in dimension one
so in dimension one um
we have this uh target distribution here
in blue and we have some particles uh
according to the
some particles distributed according to
the
sorry some particles here
whose empirical distribution
is the green curve here and the goal is
to to move the particles
in order to their empirical distribution
to fit the blocker as here
okay so once again the sampling task is
a fundamental fundamental task of
machine learning applications but i do
not tell you the way it's important just
we want to want to sample from expansion
minus f where f is not convex
and the algorithm standard version goes
in descent works as follows
so basically it will maintain the set of
particles x1 to xn
uh according to the following rule so
the location
of the particle of the particle i at
time n plus one
is equal to the location of the particle
i at time particle
n minus some some number some step size
times the sum over j so the other
particles
of degradation of f at x j n so the
particle uh the location of the particle
j at time n
times k s j n x i n
minus graduate of k s j n x i n
so here k is a is a function from from r
t to r d time times r d to r okay a real
valued function called the kernel and it
is associated to what is called the
reproduction kernel hilbert space
so the approach that we used to to to
statistical russian negotiation was to
view the task of sampling according to
the target description you start as an
optimization task
because you can always reformulate the
task of sampling as an optimization task
okay sampling is different from
optimization but you can somehow
cast the problem of sampling as a as an
optimization problem and one way to do
it is use to proceed as follows
so let me introduce the keyboard library
divergence between u and u star
okay so
this this quantity is equal to plus
infinity if mu is not absolutely
continuous with respect to mu star and
else it is equal to the integral of the
logarithm of mu over mu star with
respect to nu
and this quantity the kl
[Music]
the kl of music to mustard
is always non-negative okay so come back
lambda diverges always non-negative and
is equal to zero if and only if mu is
equal to mu star
okay so if i look at this
as this quantity as a function of mu and
i denoted v of mu this means that mu
star
is the minimizer of v okay mustard is
the only measure of it so this way we
can view the target distribution as a
minimizer of some functional
uh defined on the space of probability
measures but still it's a function the
real value function
and uh so now let me go back to to uh
stand russian english incense so as i
said uh we studied the schneiderlin
graduation but there are some
simplifying assumptions and then
one of them is that we studied russian
religion in the so-called population
limit
which means the limit where there is an
infinite number of particles
so if i denote by mu n the empirical
distribution of the particles at time n
when n goes to infinity then it's known
that that
that mu n so then you can show that that
mu n the mu n uh satisfies the following
dynamics
so from u n to go to mu n plus one
one takes the image measure of mu n by
some map okay and the map is described
here it is identity minus gamma times
uh this map here which is built as
follows it is a linear operator p mu n
okay the linear operator n which is
basically a convolution with respect to
k applied to a function called the
certain gradient of v at mu n so recall
that v is a function
defined on the set of probability
measures so for this kind of function
sometimes you can define what is called
the vessel language so kind of grid
a kind of a gradient for these functions
defined on the space of probability
measures and the vessel gradient of v
at mu is a function and this is the
sorry this is the function that is um
involved in
in
in
the population limit
okay so this is the diamond dynamics of
svg in the population limit and um
and now i'm ready to state the result so
the result the complexity results are in
terms of the so-called carnalized time
discrepancy which is a discrepancy
between probability measures
which is used to compare the to compare
probability measure so
it is defined to the the ksd between you
and mustard is defined as the
as the norm in the rkhs of uh p new
great p move associated with vietnamese
but
it's it's a discrepancy so it's used to
compare probability measures so in
particular there's many cases where
well
well if you know that the ksd between u
and u star is equal to zero
then uh mu is equal to mu star and there
are some also several cases
where um
where if
if uh
so if if the ksd goes to zero then you
end converges to new star weekly okay
so okay let's continue
um so here is the complexity result so
the the main assumption that uh
[Music]
so the main assumption uh in in
outside except the the the population
limit is an assumption on the on the
target distribution so we assume that
the target distribution satisfies some
some telegrams inequality
so this is equi
equivalently we can say that there
exists a point a and a and a real number
beta
such that uh the integral of exponential
beta times x minus a square with respect
to the target distribution is finite
okay
so this is equivalent to say that mu
star satisfies some the target
inequality called t1
and what we proved in the sequence of
two papers is that
basically
d to the power 1.5 of our epsilon
iterations are sufficient
to output
an iterate mu n such that the square ksd
is less than epsilon
okay i stopped here thank you for
listening
questions
thanks very much
so
the next the next speaker is carrie wu
[Music]